i i have to ask because i'm curious
because you've been on youtube for so
long sorry do you hate people no no no
no no no no such a [ __ ] dinosaur dude
i just think about my age
because you know youtube has gone
through a lot of distinct eras i'd say
yeah yeah what do you have a favorite
youtube era where you feel like this is
when it was the golden time of youtube
yeah yeah i i think it was probably
around
like 2011 to 2013-ish yeah yeah where
there was money to be made so you and
sponsors like people would take it
seriously enough to fund everything yeah
but yet there wasn't this idea that like
mainstream media had yeah of like anyone
can do this and become a millionaire
yeah you know what i mean i feel like it
was still very independent
and
it just felt like creativity was what
thrived most yeah yeah because i feel
like that era of youtube all of the
biggest creators at that time
they all started youtube not to make
money yeah but just because they enjoyed
the creativeness of it yeah i enjoyed
making videos and then i feel like after
that kind of progressed into people
realizing that you could make this a job
absolutely and you could like people
yeah
it's a legitimate business which is
nothing wrong with that but i feel like
part of the magic was lost i feel you
know because it kind of transitioned to
into something else you know
yeah a different mindset going into
creating things uh and around that time
or soon after
is when i think the algorithm was
introduced ah yes the illusive
the algorithm
the one god of youtube
i'm learning more now that the algorithm
really does reward the things that
people enjoy consuming yeah yeah and the
algorithm's goal well no one individual
knows
everything in and out because it's made
by so many people and it's taught to
learn
that's not scary don't worry
the algorithm does
reward the things that that do have the
highest retention they have
uh you know watching for the longest
time replaying the moments most the
highest click-through rate of what looks
most exciting so i am learning that you
can work with the new way that it's set
up but it was definitely jarring when it
first happened and no one knew or was
told what was happening just like
flipped to let's plays overnight yeah
yeah
the fastest way to make repeating
long-form content yeah people would feel
the need to watch entirely yeah oh yeah
is that because did you guys start the
gaming channel around that time yeah
yeah is that why because of the change
or was it we didn't realize we didn't
know what the reason was that these
videos were popping up but we saw
oh wait gaming videos that's becoming
really popular people want to see this
and a lot of people are asking us to
play games
i'm a gamer
i could do it did you have a hard time
when the algorithm did shift and you
were still on like you know uh scripted
you know scripts
uh sorry scripted sketches and
everything like that yeah yeah it was
definitely a hard
period i mean it didn't really affect us
as much as
yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're still fine we still
uh i looked recently we still have like
a lot of videos from that time that have
like tens of millions of views so like
it was okay
it was okay but um it definitely did
impact
the way that the videos were pushed out
initially yeah so like after the first
weekend
i remember having a higher up breathing
down my neck saying you guys usually get
a million views in the first three days
what's going on why are there you know
it was a lot of like the stress of like
what is going on we're like i don't know
no we don't
and like their their entire company and
all the x amount of employees like their
livelihoods are built on the performance
of these videos right so at that time we
were really pushed to break off and
create other side channels and
experiment with longer form content
things that required less editing
i feel so lucky being like just like a
almost always independent like a one two
man team with my own my personal channel
because that's just the pressure she's
gone yeah it's a lot less pressure yeah
okay so because like i gotta ask because
i rarely meet someone who's been on
youtube for longer than me for longer
than most of your viewers lives yeah
because
honestly
honestly
yeah nia who's like this really popular
twitch streamer and she's 19. i was like
so i made mine on youtube when you were
two
and it freaked me out that's scary it
freaked me the [ __ ] out because i found
out today actually that today out of
complete coincidence is my 15th year
anniversary on youtube
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm congratulations
so like i rarely get to ask this so what
is the secret to staying relevant for a
long period of time on youtube
you're asking that you're i'm working on
for 15. because you've been on for
longer than me so so you're the only one
i can ask for like like a actual
perspective right okay okay well we
could share perspectives here okay i
think that you might have something to
contribute okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'll be mr seven seventeen years my
senior
my senior now my youtube career uh can
watch an r-rated movie but i can't quite
vote or smoke
mine's in high school you know yeah
yeah
you're very uncomfortable about puberty
yeah yeah you're starting to get the
hang of it
yeah um but let's see so the secret
the secret is to never feel like you
have it figured out right yeah the
secret i think is to always feel like
there is something new to learn yeah uh
i i am constantly looking at the people
that are growing audiences and i'm kind
of filtering out okay this person they
have a recipe and it pleases the
algorithm
i think maybe that's why they have used
okay what can i learn from that okay
this person has a really dedicated fan
base they don't necessarily appeal to
the algorithm but they appeal to an
audience and what can i learn from them
yeah so for me it's really about
constantly learning yeah and uh when i
do interviews with bigger names uh
tomorrow i'm i'm interviewing tommy in
it
oh nice and uh you know he's got he's
he's like is he 18. he's just he said in
school right
yeah yeah but uh like i i love picking
his brain and and you know people that
are new and coming up on youtube right
now and learning
what what they see in the platform now
because it's something completely
different and i feel like there was
never a point where you as a creator on
the internet where things are so rapidly
changing there was never a point where
you will be like
got the figured it out yeah yeah and i
used to think there would be a point
that i would be like i gotta grind and
grind and grind and eventually have it
figured out and then i'll just be able
to sit back and let the thing just live
on its own
and i think that's kind of what got me
into
or convinced me that like selling to a
company in 2011 was a right idea i had
it in my head yeah the goal is to figure
this out it'll go on autopilot i can
relax and maybe do other things in my
life yeah
but what i quickly realized is that i
really love doing this and this is part
of my life that i want to retain yeah
and there will never be a point where i
feel satisfied just relaxing but also if
you sit back and relax
um
then
uh you know and it's about like yeah
yeah comfortable and you lose track of
what's
you know why things are moving in the
direction they're going and what is
relevant to the platform today yeah
because that's really interesting to
hear because like for your perspective
you've really like been one of the top
creators basically since the birth of
youtube whereas i've been on youtube for
a long time but i've it's been like on a
very very niche like topic which is
anime so i've always been able to learn
from what the bigger creators are doing
and try to apply what you know to try to
apply what everyone else is doing and
seeing if i can take that into my own my
own niche my own channel and seeing
seeing if it can grow out there and how
is that paid off like were you able to
take those those lessons and things that
you learned from the bigger youtubers
and apply it to yourself and have it pay
off yeah i mean i kind of felt like a
cheat sheet you know i kind of feel like
cheating because i'm just like you know
i'm in such a niche topic that i could
just take what i can just take what
other people are doing yeah just put it
to put it with my own content but with
you since you're one you're one of the
people setting the standards you know
you wanted people like you know i
watched and i was like okay let's see
what smart should do let's see what some
of the other bigger creators are doing
i'm like okay well i see what's
successful to them but like i feel like
being at the top of the pyramids and
trying to balance yourself is a lot
easier than climbing up from the bottom
of the pyramid and trying to like stay
relevant for sure yeah i think that some
people uh see that see have a goal
like get to the top of this pyramid just
just stay afloat up here yeah and of
course like it is much more comfortable
because you have the freedom to to kind
of
um apply more of these things that you
learn on a bigger scale yeah but at the
same time
there's so much more pressure and i
think that that's unforeseen to smaller
creators you know i had my period i left
smosh when i think we had 22 or 23
million subscribers huge amount of
subscribers huge amount of pressure i go
off and do my own thing
um channel starts with a couple million
and they're like people that don't
really know what to expect i don't know
what to give them and there was still
that pressure there from me
of
how am i going to entertain these people
who expect me to be giving the quality
of content of a 22 million subscriber
channel but now
um it's just me it's literally just me
on my my own i'm really curious about
obviously a lot of the viewers when you
said i'm leaving smosh i think a lot of
people would see that and think oh it's
just like uh he's just leaving a channel
but i imagine there was a lot of
probably behind the scenes or like
friendships that were strained by that
yeah was that like a like outside of
just a business perspective do that put
like a lot of strain on like your
personal life like leaving that and put
having to kind of
be like all right i'm leaving this big
thing like that because you know
obviously ian is there and a bunch of
your friends
well surprisingly me leaving didn't put
a strain uh in and of itself like the
idea of leaving and then me leaving yeah
that didn't exactly put a strain i think
maybe afterwards it did a little bit
because there were uh really i think it
was because audiences or viewers and
commenters really were having all these
different things that they were saying
about like oh this person's better or
this person's better or you were better
when you were here or they're better now
that they're here and i think that that
added a little bit of it was unavoidable
to see those especially yeah yeah i feel
like you can't turn off your brain from
wanting to to to keep up with the
comments not even if you're not even
trying to look for that yeah i'm trying
to see what people are thinking about
this new thing that i'm just like uh
trying to figure out and then i'm
getting inundated with all these
opinions from people and i think that
that does seep in when you're not ready
for it yeah i do wish that i was more
ready for the types of comments how the
[ __ ] can you get ready for that
there's the only way to be ready for it
i think is to live in it yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i also realized that there is a
bit of freedom in having a smaller
audience yeah so it was it was a huge
struggle and my videos when i first left
i think got a million views each for
like a couple
months and i was like oh this is i i
need to retain this and then very
quickly once i think people realize i
didn't know what i was doing i had no
channel i was like uh each week we'll
figure out something new and i hope you
watch it uh and i i quickly
lost this audience that i had and
realized that they were not there just
for me yeah and it was a little bit
disappointing at first because i thought
oh i i guess i have the freedom to do
whatever and i thought that i had
that with me and it was a wake-up call
to realize oh but you have to make good
content you can't just expect them to be
there because it's you yeah
egotistical maniac
and i
uh you know the views i think got to
about
like thirty thousand to sixty thousand
views a video or on the anthony on the
anthony padilla channel right in the
first year after wow and and at that
time
you know if videos weren't getting a
hundred thousand views or even more
people in the comments are just like
irrelevant ireland
plus ratio plus you fell off yeah yeah
yeah a lot of that you basically had to
abandon an audience for a different
style yeah obviously that's gonna happen
yeah like people don't see it like that
they're like oh your name is like what
do you mean you're not doing sketches
anymore
i thought you were gonna do your own
sketches now right but i thought that i
had to i thought i was beholden and i
think that the reason that it got to
that point is i felt like i was trapped
in this idea of yeah i need to create
sketches i need to be funny i need to
deliver something that appeases that
audience that i've learned how to
appease yeah yeah and um
i think
getting down to to you know i call them
lower numbers 30 to 60k i know a lot of
people yeah uh are up and coming and
that is a great perspective i don't want
to discount that yeah yeah but uh at the
same time
i i was like
kind of floundering around at that
number and first of all i had to get out
of my head from looking at the numbers
right it wasn't about that anymore i
realized that i had an opportunity now
to experiment without the pressure of an
audience
so that's when i started experimenting
with
all these different types of videos and
all these different types of things and
that's when i fell into
uh doing i spent a day with yeah yeah
yeah videos right and it was without
that pressure and the first few were did
have that pressure on me to be funny so
i was kind of you know i did i spent a
day with flat earthers and it was kind
of like look how
ridiculous
people are weird
but slowly
uh slowly but surely over the next um
couple months or half year i
i started realizing that i actually was
really curious about different types of
people yeah and uh i had
uh i did this video i spent today with
furries and i had a
company help me reach out to these
people and i thought they were all local
yeah when they showed up i found out
that one flew in themselves on their own
dime and then this person uh like drove
three hours to be there
and i was like i was like okay this is
and i wasn't i already wasn't planning
to like
to to say like these people are weird
but a part of me was like i don't
understand this
this is this is kind of a weird thing
yeah but
you know they get there and they're
they're saying
uh i used to watch smosh all the time
so i very quickly uh changed my
perspective with the way that i went
into that yeah it was like there's there
was no way like and it felt it felt
weird to me
uh doing that the flat earther episode
it felt weird to me like i was going
outside of my element to to give the
uh snarky commentary channel perspective
that was really popular on youtube at
the time
i realized i was kind of falling into
those tropes that were so popular yeah
yeah and i was like i just feel like i
need to just be me and have a
conversation with someone be curious
about them try to learn about their life
and
in doing so
afterward i had uh you know them reach
out to me they were really they were
really excited about the way it turned
out but also a lot of commenters were
like whoa this is the first time i've
ever seen furries represent in a way
where they were treated with respect
right and that is so weird i've never
seen that before i'm gonna send this to
my friends who don't understand me yeah
and
it was really then that i realized like
oh this is what actually feels right
this is yeah this doesn't feel like i'm
not appeasing an audience i think i
should be appeasing because it's the
trendiness of youtube at the time or
yeah or like this sense of humor that i
felt like i needed to always like be
this character that i was on smosh right
i felt like i was able to actually just
be myself
and my editor then helped me throw in
jokes but it wasn't up to me anymore i
was just making a connection with yeah